TWENTY THREE QUIRK AB TWELVE
NINETY GLORIA. US SECRETARY
TAKE THE ROLE AGUIAR-CURRY
PRESENT. LACKEY LACKEY PRESENT
BLOOM. BLOOM PRESENT FOR HER
ABOUT PRESIDENT BOERNER HORVATH
PRESIDENT RAMOS. ALMOST
PRESIDENT THREE OF US.
PRESIDENT YOU SO HELP PRESENT.
OKAY. OKAY WE'LL START WITH MR
TANG WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING AB ONE SIXTEEN. IF YOU
WANT SIXTEEN IS THE BILL THAT
STARTED OFF REGIONALLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S GENERALLY FIVE.
INTRODUCED THE IDEA OF. WHAT WE
HAVE DONE WE HAVE STRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS YOUR CALL
HE IF THESE WERE A TOOL TO SIX
HELP PART OF THE SUCCESSION FOR
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES MAVIS
ONE GOVERNMENT KNOW HOW
CRITICAL REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
FOR REALLY PROVIDE FOR
STRUCTURE HAPPENED SO IN THIS
INSTANCE GONE AWAY FROM THE
IDEA TO USE WITH TOOL THAT WE
COULD USE IT FOR. THE NOT. AT
THE EXPENSE OF OUR STATE
GENERAL FUND. THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T KNOW THE REDEVELOPMENT
DID NOT NEED TO DO TO GET A
WILL ON THE VOTERS TO ISSUE
BONDS SO WHAT THE BILL DOES IS
TO TAKE AWAY THAT VOTE
THRESHOLD. ON TO BE MORE IN
LINE WITH REGIONAL
REDEVELOPMENT ON A WEEKEND WE
THINK THIS IS VERY CRITICAL
HE'S HI IT DOES PUT IN A PUBLIC
PROCESS IS VERY SIMILAR TO THE
LAB FOR PROCESSING. LASKO
PROCESS DOES ALLOW FOR CERTAIN
NUMBER ON VOTERS TO EXPRESS
THEIR DISSATISFACTION. WITH DAN
FOR SOME FUN. ON THIS
PARTICULAR BOND. AGAIN VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT CAN BE FOR
SURE. RESPECT OR US RIGHT
BEFORE HE WHAT'S NEXT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER AWARENESS AND
SUPPORT. WHERE IS THE SAME NONE
ARE THERE NEW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. YEAH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON AS I
SAID INDEED WOLF BARRY JERVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WE'RE
SUPPOSED AB ONE SIXTEEN AGAIN
OUR CONCERN ON THIS IS THE
ELIMINATION OF ANY SORT OF
ORDER APPROVAL AT ALL FOR A
LONG TERM DEBT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE ON THE
BOOKS FOR DECADES SHOULD
REQUIRE VOTER APPROVAL. AND.
OBVIOUSLY YOU TAKE THAT AWAY
ONE CARS SO FOR THAT WE ASK.
THANK YOUR THOSE OTHERS
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE IN A
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
PHONE NINE OF IN A TEN MOTION.
THE MOTION SECOND AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN.
BEFORE YOU KNOW AGENCIES USE
THIS TOOL FOR THE HOUSE WE
THINK THIS IS VERY MUCH IN LINE
TO HAVE TO TAKE ACTION TO MAKE
IT TO MAKE THE I HAVE THESE
MORE IN LINE WITH REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES WITHOUT A SECOND'S
RIGHT RIGHT THANK YOU AND I
WILL BE IN SUPPORT OF
REBUILDING DAY SUCKED INTO AN
OCEAN IS TAKEN CURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS AGUIAR-CURRY FIVE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY TO KNOW
LACKEY LOW BLOOM. HI HELLO MY
BOERNER HORVATH NO
BOERNER HORVATH NO RAMOS ALMOST
I THREE OF US HI THIS RIVERSIDE.
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
HOPE HEALTH. VOEPEL NOW. THREE
OUT DOES NOT FIVE THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
IS AB SEVEN TWENTY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK CHAIRMAN.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF
BECAUSE THEY- WORK VERY QUICKLY
INTO THE WELL. EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE MAKES CHANGES. TO
HOW THE TRANSACTION USE TAX LAW.
IS CALCULATED IN ALAMEDA AND
SANTA CRUZ COUNTIES. OF THE
CAN'T BE MADE 2% FOR THE WAY
IT'S CALCULATED THIS
DIFFERENTLY IN PARTICULAR THE
GOVERNOR FELT THAT HE REGIONAL
PARK TAX AND REGIONAL OF SANTA
CRUZ THAT'S PROBABLY
INTERESTING. STORY TAXES SHE
GOT THE PART OF THE LOCAL THAT.
I CITIES AND COUNTIES COURSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A WIDE RANGE
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH AS
SHELTERS FOR THE HOMELESS
POLICE AND FIRE. CHANGE AGAIN
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE WILL
GO GLOBAL GOVERNMENTS OF THE
NEEDED FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED
AND THE OPTION TO GO TO VOTERS
FOR ADDITIONAL REVENUE. PROVIDE
A MUCH NEEDED GENERAL PURPOSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES SUCH
AS AN AIR PARK MAINTENANCE AND
HOMELESS PREVENTION. WITH ME
TODAY IS NEGLIGIBLE I WILL PASS.
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
FREMONT. IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IF A BILL FOR
THREE OF WHEN YOU GO FOR
FIREFIGHTERS BUT COMPLIANCE
OFFICERS TAKE YOUR WORKERS
FREMONT WHEN YOU GO TO
TRANSPORTATION FRAZIER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELL I'M MEMBERS
FIFTY VALERIE AT THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. THE
FOURTH PERSON I MENTION COMPANY
MUCH NEED STAFFING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OTHERS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION AND I'M
SURE MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON.
YEAH. DRUGS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION GOING TO FUNERALS.
AND THAT WE'RE OPPOSE LESSONS
WE SUPPOSE MANY SIMILAR SALES
TAX AUTHORIZATION MEASURES OVER
THE YEARS SALES TAX IS A VERY
AGGRESSIVE. HOW IS IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK OVER TWENTY
FIVE LAST COUNT AND HAS A VERY
KIND PERSON SALES TAX RATE. AND
THERE'S JUST LITTLE
JUSTIFICATION YEAH FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES INCREASE. FURTHER
AGGRESSIVE TAXATION WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED WITH THE SANTA CRUZ
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT DISTRICT
OF PEACE IN THIS BILL WHICH IS
INFUSED WITH THEM I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE HEARD THE FIRST TIME
AROUND. WE'RE CONCERNED IN WHAT
APPEARS TO BE OPPRESSED.
BECAUSE OF THE DISTRICT IS
SEEKING TO EXEMPT THEMSELVES
FROM THE 2% BROADWAY BRAIN
CELLS HAVE ENTIRELY NOT JUST
PERSPECTIVE FOR FUTURE TAXES
CORRECT FOR. YOUR TAXES ALREADY
AND- YEAH THAT IS PRESENT
CITING ITEM THING. YEAH THERE'S
NO HISTORY OF THAT. AND THAT'S
CONCERNING THE US SO BEYOND
JUST THE REGRESSIVITY A LOCAL
TAX AUTHORIZATIONS AND BRING
OUT YOUR ATTENTION ALSO ASK
CRIMINALS. THANK YOU IS ANYONE
ELSE OPPOSITION. SAYING NONE OF
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
YES. I JUST WANNA CONFIRM THIS
AND CHANGES AND AMENDMENTS
ADDED TO THIS WILL NOT AFFECT
THE TWO THIRDS VOTER APPROVAL
THRESHOLD IS THAT CORRECT OKAY
SO THERE'S TWO ON. DIFFERENT
RACIAL FOR STUDENTS. IF IT'S
FOR A SPECIFIC PURPOSE THERE'S
A TWO THIRDS THAT REMAINS A TWO
THIRDS IS SPEAK GENERAL
GOVERNMENT IT'S 50% PLUS ONE
SEVEN MILLION FIFTY PERCENT. BY
THE VOTER THRESHOLDS ARE NOT.
CHANGED AT ALL GREAT AND THE
OTHER ONE IS NOT THIS DOESN'T
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT. FOR
SENDING THESE THINGS TO THE
CORRECT. ABSOLUTELY LET'S GO TO
THE VOTERS AND WE MUST YEAH 50%
PLUS ONE. TWO THIRDS. ON WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AFTER ASKING FOR.
I HEAR THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION I'M WILLING TO
PROVIDE A COURTESY AYE
CONSIDERING THAT IT'S SO LATE
IN THE SESSION BUT I PROBABLY
WILL BE VOTING NO ON THE FOUR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMITTEE OKAY
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WITH THE
SENATE THE MOTION AND A SECOND
OF WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH.
TO ME LIKE THIS THE MOTOR.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO CONCURRENT SAID
AGUIAR-CURRY. I LACKEY LACKEY
NO BLOOM HI BLOOM AYE BURNER
FOR ABOUT HI BOERNER HORVATH I
RAMOS RIGHT FROM ASIDE
THREE OF US THREE OF US. I
ROBERT RIVAS FIVE EVERYONE JUST
FIVE OF HEALTH. HELL NO. SIX
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU ALL. THANK
YOU. MR GLORIA'S HERE WILL
THERE YES. WHO ARE YOU HIDING
THIS IS A GOOD TIME. ALRIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA RUN AB TWELVE NINETY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. TWELVE NINETY TALK
ABOUT MYSELF SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM. THIS BILL WOULD JUMP
START IMPORTANT PROJECT
PROCEEDING WITH WATER SECURITY
KNOWN BACK HOME WATER THIS IS A
MULTI YEAR PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
FIVE ONE THIRD OF SAN DIEGO'S
DRINKING WATER LOOK BY THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. USING A
PROVEN PURIFICATION TECHNOLOGY
TO CLEAN. RECYCLED WATER TO THE
STATE HIGH QUALITY CREAKING.
HE'S ONE OF THIS PROJECT IS
FUNDED IN LARGE PART BY LOW THE
STATE WATER BOARD NEARLY SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FROM OUR STATE FOR ALL THE MOST
FUN. DESPITE THIS INVESTOR WORK
ON THE PROJECT HAS CRISIS OFF
HOLD BECAUSE OF LITIGATION
CLAIMING THE CITY VIOLATED
LOCAL INITIALLY KNOWN AS- A-
PROHIBITS MANDATED POCKET LABOR.
THIS BILL WOULD REMEDY THIS
ISSUE BY LANDING FEEL IS
CONDITION OVERSEEING THE STATE
FUNDS I ALREADY MENTIONED. I
WOULD NOTE THAT MEASURE A
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZES PLA'S
IF REQUIRED BY STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW. REQUIRING THE USE OF THE
LA ON THIS IMPORTANT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT WE CAN
PROMOTE EFFICIENT AND TIMELY
COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT. AND
MOVE BEYOND THE LEGAL
UNCERTAINTY. THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS FOR THE CITY RATE PAYERS.
THIS BILL SUPPORT BY
ENVIRONMENTALISTS LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS BUSINESS AND
WATER AGENCIES ABOUT MYSELF AND
CENTER ATKINS RESPECTFULLY ASK
AYE VOTE WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON
IS GOING FEDERAL ABOUT THE CITY
OF COUNTY WATER. THIRTY AS IS
IDEAS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION.
GENTLEMAN. A GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ONE FOR A
WITH SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY HI IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL EVEN THOUGH SAN DIEGO IS
HOME TO THREE POINT THREE
MILLION PEOPLE REPRESENTING OUR
REGION AT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
PLUS BILLION DOLLAR REGIONAL
ECONOMY THE REGION'S TILL THE
END OF A VERY LONG WATER PIPE
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE VERY FEW
RELATIVELY FEW OPTIONS FOR
WATER SUPPLY RELIABLE
DIFFERENCE LAID BACK COMMUNITY
FROM DROUGHT TO PROTECT THAT
REGIONAL ECONOMY. DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THE REGION'S INVESTED
ABOUT THREE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE PAST COUPLE
DECADES TO PROMOTE REGIONAL
SELF SUFFICIENCY IN THE
EMPLOYMENT STATE LONG POLICY TO
REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON THE
DELTA AS IF YOU'VE WATER SUPPLY
SOURCE WE'RE STILL SUBJECT TO
PROLONG DROPPED AND THAT'S
DESPITE INVESTMENTS IN WATER
TRANSFERS AND REGIONAL SERVICE
STORAGE GROW MORE STORAGE
AGGRESSIVE WATER CONSERVATION
SO MAYBE RECYCLING. THE NEXT IN
LINE PROTECT THAT REGION THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE AND THE REGIONAL ECONOMY
THIS IS THE. SAME YOUR WATER
PROGRAM THAT AMOUNTS FOR
TREATMENT PROGRAM. VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SO WE MEMBERS
LAURIE SEPARATES TO JUMP START
THAT CONSTRUCTION AND WE CAN
TALK ABOUT CONSTRUCTION
TIMELINE ON SCHEDULE SO THAT.
OUR BRUNCH BECOME ONLINE AS
PROJECTED AND IMPROVE THE-
IMMENSELY BACK MAYBE FROM
FUTURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT
SURE MEMBERS THIS IDEA IS ONLY
HALF OF THE STATE OF THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING THANK YOU YOU KNOW
SOMEONE NUMBER IN THE CURRENT
TIME FOR US ALL. AS TRYING TO
ADDRESS A CRITICAL ISSUE WITH
REGARDS TO WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT
THE STATE IS A PARTNER WITH THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO THE TRY TO
GET THIS PROBLEM UP AND
RUNNING. FROM IT DEALS WITH
FIXING WHAT WE CALL A
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED AND
MISSION CAM THOUSAND AND
TWELVE. WHERE THE HOME IS A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS WENT
TO THE VOTERS TO BASICALLY HAND
FELT THE CITY. DID NOT HAVE ANY.
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS AT THE
TIME BUT THE BAND THOSE POSH.
BOB SAN DIEGO IS A CHARTER CITY
WE ARE DEFINITELY ENGAGED IN
THAT INITIATIVE AND AN
OPPOSITION. BUT NONE THE LESS
OF THE PROPONENTS ONE AND
TURNED OUT TO BE RATHER A
DECEPTIVE CAMPAIGN. AND SO WHAT
WE THEN FOLLOWED UP WITH WAS
WAS AN INCENTIVE TO BASICALLY
CREATE. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SAN
DIEGO TO HAVE THE OPTION OF
UTILIZING PROJECT. LABOR
AGREEMENTS IF THERE WAS STATE
INVOLVEMENT IN. AND SO EVEN
THOUGH. THE BILLS WERE PASSED
THERE WAS STILL SOME OF
DISCUSSIONS OVER HOW THAT
INITIATIVE WOULD APPLY FOR
STATE FUNDED PROJECTS AND SO.
THE UPON AS A PROJECT LABOR
UNIONS THEMSELVES AN EFFORT NOT
TO BE RESTRICTING THE CITY TO
THEIR OWN INITIATIVE FROM ST
CALLER TO CLAIM THAT THIS IS
THE PROPOSITION ITSELF WOULD
ALLOW THAT INVESTMENT TO
CONTINUE. NOW THEY'RE SAYING
THE OPPOSITE SO THEY CAN'T
REALLY HAVE IT BOTH WAYS I CAN
SAY FOR ALL YOU CAN USE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS WHETHER STATE
INVESTMENT AND NOW. YEAH DAHLE
SUDDEN WHEN THERE'S ACTUALLY.
STATE MONEY INVOLVED THEN
FORGET ABOUT HOW. THE FACT THIS
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS ARE
WIDELY USED BY PRIVATE
INDUSTRY. IS WIDELY USED BY
PUBLIC AS WELL YOU SEE THE
CRANES BEHIND ON THE- SOUTH
SIDE OF THE BUILDING ALL OF
THOSE FRAMES ARE ARE UNION
CRANES THOSE PROJECTS ARE STATE
PROJECTS. ALL THE PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS THAT WERE. INSERTED
INTO WITH STATE OF BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL WE HAVE FOUR
HOUSES WE HAVE SCHOOLS WE HAVE
DIFFERENT PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE WHERE THE LOCAL ENTITIES
UTILIZE PROJECT WE WILL BRING
TO TRY TO GET MORE MOBILE
HIGHER. THEY TRY TO TARGET
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH WHEN AND
EMANCIPATION FROM THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AND ALSO RETURNING
VETERANS AND SAN DIEGO THAT TO
A CRITICAL MUNITY THAT IS
ASSISTED GREATLY BY HAVING A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT FOR
THOSE WE- ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION OF
THE- SHARE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BELIEVE IT LIKE THE CYBER
PERCENT THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA THE
SAN DIEGO AND CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE ALREADY THE LARGEST
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA WITH
UNION CONTRACTORS THAT HAVE
MASTER LABOR AGREEMENTS WITH
OUR PARTNERS SUCH AS LABOR'S
HANDED THE OPERATION YEARS. WE
ALSO REPRESENT NONUNION
CONTRACTORS WHO SOURCE THEIR
PUBLIC WORK FORCE FROM
CERTIFICATED SIX ARE
CERTIFICATED. THE I. R.
ACCREDITATION PROGRAMS. THIS IS
A VERY UNCOMFORTABLE SITUATION
YOU'RE TAKEN AGREE MORE WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SOME OF YOUR
WITNESSES AND THAT THIS PROJECT
IS CRITICAL AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
IN SAN DIEGO IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THE CITY PASSED AN
ORDINANCE OF LED BY THE VOTERS.
THAT MADE IT SO THAT THERE WAS
A PROHIBITION ON MANDATORY.
PROJECT LABOR. NO PROHIBITION
ON VOLUNTARY DEAL IS BUT A
PROHIBITION ON MANDATORY FIELD.
THE INITIATIVE ALSO SAID THAT
THERE COULD BE ANY
DISCRIMINATION BETWEEN UNION
AND NONUNION CONTRACTORS SO
LONG AS THEIR WORKFORCE WAS
SEALED IN TRAINED AND DEALT
WITH CERTIFICATED PROGRAMS SUCH
AS- THE ONE THAT AGENCIES SAN
DIEGO FOR. WOULD YOU HAVE FOR
YOU HERE IS A MEASURE THAT
CONDITIONS STATE MONEY. TO THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO FOR THIS ONE
PROJECT BASED ON THE NEED OR IN
THIS CASE BASED ON THE FACT
THAT SAN DIEGO MUST PASS APPEAL
LAY GRADING A COLLISION COURSE
HERE WITH MEASURE RIGHT. UP
UNTIL NOW THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WAS ABLE TO PROCURE PUT OUT
THIS AND THERE WAS NO ISSUE BUT
THIS PROJECT YOUR VIOLATE.
MEASURE RIGHT THE AUTHOR IN
THIS IS IN THIS MEASURE IS
ATTEMPTING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
AND I UNDERSTAND WHY. A WAY BY
WHICH TO RENDER MEASURE NAY
INVALID THE PROBLEM THOUGH IS
THAT MEASURE HEY HOW'S. THAT
PIECE THAT DEALS WITH THE.
DISCRIMINATION PEACE BETWEEN
UNION AND NONUNION. SO IF YOU
MANDATE APL LAID OUT THERE YOU
RUN INTO CONFLICT WITH MEASURE
RACE SO WE DON'T BELIEVE. THAT
THIS MEASURE UNFORTUNATELY WILL
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS THE
PROCESS OR WE YOU SHOULD BE
UNDER ANY ILLUSION THAT WILL
EITHER. YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF
ISSUES IN ADDITION TO MEASURE
RIGHT. YOU'VE GOT TO THE HEART
OF THIS NATURE THAT CHARTER
CITIES ARE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
THEIR HOME RULE WHEN IT COMES
TO PREPARING PROJECTS.
FURTHERMORE YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE
GOT UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT WHEN IT RELATES TO
MUNICIPAL AFFAIRS. OWNERS SUCH
AS THE CITY SAN DIEGO CAN
REGULATE HOW YOU BROKE YOUR
PROJECTS BUT REGULATORS AND
FUNDERS SUCH AS A STATE IN THIS
CASE DON'T HAVE THAT ABILITY SO
THE DISTINCTION I THINK IS ONE
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. BUT
NOTWITHSTANDING THAT FACT WERE
UNDER NO ILLUSION THAT THIS
MEASURE HAS TREMENDOUS SUPPORT
AND POLITICAL FORCE BEHIND IT
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT'S OR
EXHORTATION THAT THIS WILL
CONTINUE THE LITIGATION AND
FURTHER SOLVE THIS PRO ABOUT.
THIS PROJECT SO FOR. THOSE
REASONS WE URGE AND OPPOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION. SINGER ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES. ALL OF THIS
YEAR'S OR POLITICAL. IT SAYS
THIS IS YOUR INITIATIVE IS A
POLITICAL ONE IT WAS NOT YOUR
INITIATIVE IS LIKE ONE OF THE
POLITICAL ONE. SO IT ALSO I
FOLLOWED. HEY QUITE CLOSELY
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS OUT OF MY
JURISDICTION IN ANOTHER CITY.
AND. IT WAS APPROVED BY 58% OF
THE VOTE. SO SAN DIEGO WANTED
TO MAINTAIN THE FREEDOM FROM
THE LA IS IN ORDER TO LOWER THE
PRICE OF DIFFERENT. PROJECTS
NOW I SELDOM YOU'LL BE KILLED
THE GREAT I SELDOM GO AGAINST
THE WATER PEOPLE BECAUSE I LOVE
YOU OKAY YOU DO REALLY GREAT
WORK IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. OF WE
SPENT ALMOST ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. IMPROVING OUR
WHOLE WATER SYSTEM STORAGE
EXCEPTION. INCLUDING
DESALINATION AND OTHER THINGS
THAT OUR FUTURE MAYOR WITH
APPROVED. LET'S DO COLLEAGUES
IS. THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR'S
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS ONLY
TWELVE POINT 8% OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PRIVATE
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE BELONG
TO A UNION THAT MEANS EIGHT OUT
OF TEN CONSTRUCTION WORKERS DO
NOT BELONG TO A UNION YOU WOULD
BE PRECLUDING THAT. THAT'S WHY
THE LAWSUIT IS THE LAWSUIT.
ALSO IT'S BEEN PROVEN BY
VARIOUS TAXPAYER FUNDED SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. THAT THE
OLD WAYS AND 12218% WHEN
COMPARED TO SIMILAR PROJECTS
NOT REQUIRING DELAYS AND THEN
JUST OF WRAP THIS UP WE'VE
HEARD FROM ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS BUT ALSO IN
OPPOSITION IS THE SAKE OF SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER. INDEPENDENT
ROOFING CONTRACTORS AND THE
WESTERN ALLIES. THANK YOU THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE. OKAY IN NEW
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION. MOVIE
BILL. THE MOTION AND A SECOND.
SELECT THOSE YEAH THANK YOU I
WILL BE SEEING SOME PART OF THE
BILL THE DAY I KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT TO YOUR LOCAL
DISTRICT WHICH IS A FIVE
SOMETHING YOU GUYS WORKING ON
I'M SURE YOU'LL IRON OUT
WHATEVER I NEED TO IRON OUT BUT
I WILL BE IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL TODAY SECRETARY TAKES A
LITTLE A LITTLE FROM MOTIONS TO
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE. I'D LIKE. HI
LACKEY. BROWN HI. I THANK.
REMEMBER ABOUT FIVE ALMOST FIVE
MONTHS I. THIS RIVERSIDE ROBERT.
THIRTY OF THIS TITLE TOWN NO NO
NO. SIX TO TEN OKAY OPEN THE
SIX TO YOUR BILL ITSELF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR. WELL THAT'S
NOT INSURANCE I NEED TO CHANGE
MY VOTE ON THE SEVEN TWENTY
THREE OKAY VOTE OKAY. I KNOW